Before getting into the algorithmic details
of the genome assembly, allow
me to introduce a crazy, yet similar
problem to
the genome assembly problem.
It is the newspaper explosion problem.
We have multiple copies of the same New
York Times newspaper.
We put them on a pile of dynamite and
trigger
the explosion.
But please do not do it at home, this is
just hypothetical.
The explosion tears the newspaper into
pieces.
Some of these pieces got burnt completely.
Some of these big, got burnt
just partially.
A question: what did the newspaper say?
Well, in order to reconstruct the
newspaper from these
remaining pieces, there's a very important
intuition behind.
We use the overlapping information to
construct the newspaper.
In this picture, you see there are two
pieces,
and we can see that they have overlapping
information.
So, we merge these two pieces into one
bigger piece and
continue the process.
If you are lucky, then you are
going to see the newspaper, and the
content of the New York
Times in June the 27th is about the human
genome.
Now, I am ready to describe
the genome sequencing and assembly in the
language of the newspaper explosion problem.
Similar to the newspaper explosion
problem, when we have multiple copies of
the same newspaper, here we also have
multiple copies of the same genome.
In this slide, you may count that we have
four copies,
but in reality we have millions of copies.
Also, similar
to the process that the
explosion tears the newspaper into pieces,
we also fragment the DNA into smaller
fragments.
These short fragments are called reads.
Some reads disappear,
and the task is: from these remaining
pieces, reconstruct the original genome.
Remember, there is no positional
information available.
So, a way to solve this puzzle is to apply
the same intuition as
you solved the newspaper explosion puzzle:
Use the overlapping information.
If you see two reads, here, they have
an overlapping fragment,
then you reconcile these pieces
into
a single piece and move further.
So this is the overall picture of the
genome sequencing and assembly.
You have multiple copies of the genome.
The sequencing machine generates reads, and
the task of the genome
assembly is: from these reads,
reconstruct the original genome.
What makes genome sequencing so difficult?
Genome is like a
book written in the alphabet of
nucleotides, A, T, C, G.
But its length is 3 billion.
But unlike we read a book, a modern
sequencing machine cannot read
from the start to the end of "this book",
but instead they
can only shred the genome and generate
short reads.
So, some people think that the genome
puzzle is actually a giant puzzle.
But please remember this one is not
similar to
the normal jigsaw puzzle, where pieces do
not overlap.
In the genome puzzle, because reads
overlap,
so this should be called an overlapping
puzzle.